hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you so I couldn't
give you a big one I [ __ ] up my voice
going all the way back to San Jose
groove back.the San Jose gigs I don't
know what I did I know what I did I was
imitating somebody yelling I was having
too much fun I didn't come from my
diaphragm and I [ __ ] choked up and I
just [ __ ] blew the voice out that's
what I did I overspent the main rotor
and my [ __ ] throat
it's what happened so now I I got to go
easy you know I got drink a little
throat coaching you know anyways what's
going on how you guys doing are you
feeling good I get energized are you
excited about the [ __ ] weekend I've
actually been working out finally I'm
still eating like a [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
haven't been dropped that much weight
but I feel better you know what it is
I'm at this [ __ ] age I swear to God I
have one sip of this or one bite of that
and it just [ __ ] me it's unbelievable I
swear to God if I didn't work out I
would be like I would look like every
other [ __ ] [ __ ] walking around the
mall that's all it is
I'm really starting to believe that a
lot of people and I was kidding no we
shove a bunch of cake down our throats I
just I don't I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is I know I was just weird how I said
that I I ate like a [ __ ] Olympian
until about 3:00 4:00 in the afternoon I
work out like a soccer mom but I eat
like a [ __ ] Olympian does my
shoulders on my shoulders coming around
by the way so I'm doing like the
elliptical and that type of [ __ ] but
right up until about 3:00 I [ __ ] kill
it you know and then the weakness starts
coming in like a [ __ ] cold front like
a rainstorm the clouds start forming
around 3:00 or 3:30 in the afternoon and
I feel myself get a week going come on
bill come on veggies veggies bezzie
shoving down your piehole
that's me batting that's been putting
[ __ ] plywood over the windows
you know before I do something stupid
and then just you know I don't know I
keep trying to do this thing when I'm
gonna be done eating around 6 o'clock at
night and then just drink waters the
rest of time and if I get hungry I'm
just gonna have a little bit of celery
now I know salaries on the Dirty Dozen
list of [ __ ] pesticides it's
basically anything where they just spray
it directly on like cantaloupes good
because they spray the [ __ ] on them you
know the [ __ ] Ebola you know what I
mean the AIDS virus whatever the [ __ ]
they do to keep the mosquitoes away they
spread and spray it right on the [ __ ]
cantaloupe but it doesn't get to the
part that you eat and you don't lick the
outside of it you know the way Fat Joe
licked it the bottom of his sneakers and
the MTV Cribs I will never get over that
it's like dude those were made in a
sweatshop just cuz you didn't walk
around New York and if you have no
[ __ ] idea
go get it anyways
the [ __ ] was I talking about so celery
you know cuz I'll spray it right on it
cuz doesn't have a husk or whatever the
[ __ ] it is so this person tells you well
just go get organic salary salary salary
just get organic celery and I wanted to
be like lady how to [ __ ] you don't
know where the [ __ ] any of this [ __ ] is
I think it all comes from the same
goddamn farm oh my god yeah well no one
looks greener than those ones call them
on organic that's about ready to go bad
say that's organic and they'll think
that the reason why it's rotting is
because you know because it's so [ __ ]
fresh I don't know so tonight I try to
do like the celery have just a little
bit half a spoonful of sugar no half
half a spoonful of peanut butter to try
to get me through and you know you just
go to bed like upset that's what
happened if you're eating right you go
to upset you're not in a good mood
alright now a lot of [ __ ] nutrition
is died
tsch ins [ __ ] personal trainers
[ __ ] CrossFitters and all that will
say like no you shouldn't feel hungry at
all because your body would be full of
all the it tight clothes dressing like a
goddamn x-men to do [ __ ] curls
workout clothes at the dumbest stupidest
[ __ ] I was watching an old Odd Couple
boat oh my favorite part of that song is
when the horn section kicks in Wow back
then when there was actually a [ __ ]
orchestra it wasn't some guy with a
laptop [ __ ] pump in his fists like
he's gonna reboot the Arsenio show for
the third [ __ ] time it wasn't like
that
it was actual it was somebody that
practiced the [ __ ] trombone since he
was knee-high fight in the Dust Bowl
during the Depression right before
[ __ ] Pearl Harbor and he had to beat
out 50,000 other tuba players everybody
trying to put their own stamp on you
know he's sitting out there all [ __ ]
nervous knowing his dad's gonna give him
the belt if he doesn't [ __ ] book it
right he's on the other side of the door
just listening to other people audition
you know I thought that guy nailed it
I was watching I'm getting off track
here I was watching that show and Oscar
yeah Oscar had come from the gym and he
just had on a gray sweatshirt and gray
sweatpants you'd have to go in they're
all [ __ ] aerodynamic like he was
doing a time trial in the Tour de France
all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] that Nike makes
who's kidding who that children make in
the Nike factory you know before they
try to jump out the [ __ ] window or is
that Apple I have no idea it's all
alleged I know they did in Italy
it's fake news those children are happy
they put the nets outside the window
because they enjoyed jumping into them
it's a religious holiday mock I gotta
work on my Trump I got to work my
trumpets whoo-hoo that is rough you know
that's all the [ __ ] you need now
everybody's got all they got all the
[ __ ] but he's walking around dressed
like Captain America oh my god I saw a
[ __ ] show at the mall yesterday an
absolute [ __ ] she was such a [ __ ]
show I actually was looking around for
someone to be trying to fill me for my
reaction I'd gone to the mall again
that's twice in a week I never go to the
mall twice in a [ __ ] week and this
time I went to the Grove now if you
don't if you don't live in LA okay
the Grove is basically it's like going
to Times Square on New Year's Eve except
it's a mall it's a [ __ ] nightmare
all right but I was going down there
because I'm a man
Deana Adler Steven Adler's mom who wrote
the wonderful book well actually a
tragic book and then it comes out this
sucks you know it starts off with
sunshine
it gets really [ __ ] cloudy couple of
pages and then it comes out again it's a
great book called sweet child of mine
and she was doing a book signing and as
I said I was going to be down there
and you know so I went down there the
book signing was great
and her son's Steven and Jamie came down
that dude Steven Adler's [ __ ]
hilarious it was a huge crowd thank you
to everybody who showed up who listened
to my podcast and went down there I
think you know had a couple of mm
podcast listeners down that I ran into
so he was [ __ ] killing killing say
whatever he wanted to some woman in the
crowd she's like Steve I do you remember
me back in the day I used to stand out
from the rainbow he's like I had I did
I'd [ __ ] you
he said that Barnes and Noble's bar the
noble is it I don't know I don't read
Barnes & Noble or Nobles and be a final
Stanley Cup final a to Stanley Cup
Finals I can't remember in this [ __ ]
bookstore in a microphone he said that
just completely might be like a comedian
that just didn't give a [ __ ] whether
they ever worked the club again it was
[ __ ] amazing and he absolutely
destroyed and and they sold a bunch of
books so order one today
it's an incredible read man I'm telling
you it's [ __ ] brutal it's [ __ ]
like if he already read his his what
that Steven's was brutal enough but now
to hear the mothers side going through
the pain to try and help him out I tell
you I'm gonna be honest with you I
haven't gotten through it yet that's how
[ __ ] brutal is I just got into the
part where Stephen starts going off the
rails I'm just like out man I gotta go
like one chapter at a time in other
words she pulls no punches so definitely
check that out if you can so anyways
back to the [ __ ] show so I'm going to
the mall right and I pull in I've a lay
right I've a lay like a [ __ ] big shot
cuz this is our this is two things or I
don't give a [ __ ]
I'm usually a frugal [ __ ] all right
my Malcolm young t-shirt right and I
don't spend any [ __ ] money cuz I know
how this business works right when you
go out you buy something flashy it's a
look at him look at him look at that
freckled [ __ ] he thinks he made it then
they come over they [ __ ] yank it
right out from underneath that's not I'm
going out huh
not not me nope I'm gonna buy some strip
malls I'm gonna start having some money
coming in from outside of this v8 it was
kidding oh it's gonna be a sad ending
just like everybody else is you know
I'll come walking out one day on some
[ __ ] telethon you know my jaw [ __ ]
quivering uncontrollably and you guys
all gonna be like mom what have you used
to be so young right and all you guys
will have to shut it off cuz I'll look
so bad it's gonna remind you of your own
mortality right there you go there's
something to look forward to this
weekend sorry
anyways plowing ahead here so I'm
walking to them to the mall okay and
half shirts are back or as they call
them crop tops all the lay all the
ladies who [ __ ] eat right or wearing
them you know what I mean
and I'm sure the fatties at some point
are gonna hate them and say that those
crop tops are sexist and they're
creating an impossible body image and
they're gonna blame those women that
actually took the time to [ __ ] push
themselves away at 5 o'clock and just
sit there eating celery and [ __ ] past
that drinking water hating themselves
you know here's all the people that are
gonna resent the crop tops where are
they huh oh that's sitting there having
a great [ __ ] time to get in gelato
with a side of cake that something fat
people do you know I'm [ __ ] blowing
up this spot I live with a fatty I did
I'm telling you I have fat friends okay
all of that [ __ ] all of those ice creams
that you see those unholy matrimony 's
of [ __ ] candy bars and ice cream like
who then they'll [ __ ] thought of that
I'll do bad people bad people fat people
right they all came up with that [ __ ]
they all came up with that [ __ ] late at
[ __ ] night they're like junkies ok
and what happens is is after a while
doing heroin isn't enough you got to put
a little coke in there and then you got
a speedball it so the fat [ __ ] person
speedball is when you take it you if you
even get fat you listen this you know
it's [ __ ] true you know you shouldn't
be doing it you know you're excited you
know you're excited right and you know
you got the ice cream at home right and
you stopped at the red light you look
over to the left and there's at 7-eleven
right in that demon in you just goes hey
I'm you driving then go get a zagnut bar
come on you have vanilla ice cream at
home that's kind of plain and he's
take it up a notch mind you know you
want to do it you know you start crying
well Sam you like ice cream yeah I said
make a left turn drive in there get hurt
not bark and you [ __ ] turn in there
and you buy the [ __ ] thing right like
you're going in there to rent a porn
back in the 90s an element of shame you
don't want to make eye contact but you
don't want to look away you know because
they got a couple of JIP films in there
you know you got to have that maybe I'm
gonna rent Sleepless in Seattle look on
your face right as you walk into the
pawn shop except it's to 7-eleven and
you're walking past all the other
fatties and the [ __ ] people
you know the junkies buying those
[ __ ] hot dogs that have been there
since [ __ ] Ronald Reagan got shot
right you [ __ ] go in there you
probably grab a couple of healthy things
like maybe one of their [ __ ] bananas
that's still green you know the hand of
the kid that picked it you know his
fingerprints are still [ __ ] on it
right then you just walk right up to the
cash register at the last second you try
to make it seem like you know it would
that be all and you got to be like yeah
right now you get the [ __ ] zagnut bar
and then you take that [ __ ] thing
home right driving home now excited
while hating yourself excited passing
over the double line into your [ __ ]
house right you put on [ __ ] Netflix
and then you sit down and what do you do
you got to take the ice cream out now
this part is the hardest it's killing
you you got to let the ice cream melt a
little bit right so you can [ __ ]
dream that goddamn candy bar right in
there all right that's what fatties do
I don't what I'm talking about here so
I'm at the [ __ ] mall okay
I gotta fill up a half hour okay I got
to have some tangents here you know you
want to do an fr word though material
you want to try to fill it up right so
anyway so I'm walking through so this
[ __ ] you know this is another person
that I can't stand you know cuz I'm so
goddamn perfect right the [ __ ] person
just refuses to admit that they're old
you know I don't mean like just year-old
just go sit there on the [ __ ] couch I
don't mean that
you know definitely get out there you
know get yourself some air but you know
put on some sunscreen you old [ __ ] okay
the people that you passed a certain age
and they're still trying to keep up with
young people with the styles and [ __ ] I
saw this woman write tragic traffic
[ __ ] 80 yards you could tell there
was no father ever in her life okay
which is sad but you know at some point
you got you you know you got to put your
tits aways and you got to look in the
mirror and just be like look all right
so he wasn't that [ __ ] that guy who's a
piece of [ __ ] I'm worth something this
lady did not have that
okay she's [ __ ] walking okay she is
like I don't know what age she was she
should have been 33 there was something
about her said 33 but she looked like 47
and she wasn't good shape for her
[ __ ] AIDS but she's wearing the crop
top okay and she doesn't have a flat
stomach she has just that little bit of
it's cut belly whatever you call it
right so it's hanging over in the front
it's hanging on the back and she's
wearing a [ __ ] crop top and the crop
top said [ __ ] on it she's where are
these little short shorts these [ __ ]
high heels and you know you know the
lady's feet after [ __ ] three decades
of sticking yourself in horseshoes do
your feet up beat up you know you see
like the heels there's like those white
circles from like no blood supply and
[ __ ] and it's just like oh my god get
yourself a pair of flat shoes you know
I'll put on a sport coat and you put on
like some something flowing you did your
time like young people be young so she
[ __ ] walks by and I I don't know the
only excuse I can make was maybe she was
a hooker she was a hooker I don't have a
problem god bless her you know what I
mean if she had if she had a [ __ ] I
don't know what you would call it a
goddamn charity I would give to it but
if she's just a regular [ __ ] person
mean [ __ ] Yeah right
and once again half the reason why she
was driving me nuts is it just reminded
me of how old I was I was like I am old
enough that I was alive when that woman
was still hot
and I'm not gonna apologize for any of
this [ __ ] if you're gonna walk out okay
you got to know your age all of these
[ __ ] you know you know people tell
you that you know you know I mean 50
cent in 40 you know [ __ ] says that 50
year olds know 50s 50 put some [ __ ]
clothes on now geez I'm on a [ __ ]
tangent here not a rent it's not a rent
don't even say it's a [ __ ] ran all
you guys have ruined that word rent rent
is your complete you're barely holding
your [ __ ] together rent goes with raving
like Hall and Oates
rant and raving all right this whole
thing that hey he talked about the same
subject in a reasonably calm tone for
the last [ __ ] seven minutes he's on a
rant you know you know you know defines
it that [ __ ] Millennials and you know
why that is because they wear helmets
when they ride bicycles and they had
playdates and they had helicopter
parents so then and didn't even know
what yelling is god help us god help us
when Isis that doesn't have a plane or a
boat somehow figures out how to [ __ ]
get over here from the other side of the
world you know in their pajamas or
whatever the [ __ ] it is they're doing
over there okay god help us when they
show up and the Millennials have to
fight them you know Jesus Christ
anyways so here's the good side of it
the syphon fact that DNA ads are sold a
bunch of [ __ ] books there's a store
over there out of Detroit Michigan and
it's called shinola so I'm going to
shine I immediately I gotta go in there
because of that old-school expression my
dad always said oh Christ that guy
Christ he doesn't know [ __ ] from shinola
that was a great one that one am i
another one my favorite my dad krycek I
could [ __ ] up a free lunch that one made
me laugh every time he [ __ ] said it
cuz he always said it's about the right
person and then just just doing the math
like what would you have to do to [ __ ]
up a free lunch where you can literally
have the person
you know [ __ ] you go somewhere else to
get your food you know like what would
you have to do the guys giving you a
free lunch what would you say to the guy
other than thank you anyways
so there's an expression it was kind of
a Midwest thing right I think you don't
know [ __ ] from shinola
now shinola was a shoe polish that was
in Michigan I believe outside of Detroit
so the expression going you don't know
[ __ ] from shinola basically means you
wouldn't know if you were shining your
shoes with shoe polish or [ __ ] it's
basically saying you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so I'm like all right shinola I got to
go in there so I come walking in there
and the first thing I say to the guy was
like dude I had to come in here are you
familiar with the expression you don't
know [ __ ] from shinola he goes
absolutely that's how we came up with
the name of this store so evidently this
company they make all these cool [ __ ] in
America in Detroit a city that needs
[ __ ] industry great goddamn City just
waiting for someone to invest in it they
make all of this stuff so I [ __ ] go
in there dude you got to look these
things up man
aside from all the watches and all the
[ __ ] they had and they had these [ __ ]
bikes you know I'm actually gonna post
the video and I'm and I I say hey Dean
check this [ __ ] out because I was
sending at the Dean Del Ray because Dean
Del Ray is is a connoisseur of fine [ __ ]
the man does not own a lot of [ __ ] but
the [ __ ] that he owns is fine she
top-of-the-line [ __ ] so they had
bicycles in there and they look like
paper boy bikes from the 1950s you know
and I I [ __ ] did my time from third
grade to ninth grade till I [ __ ] I
did that all the way up to high school
you know so I always liked those bikes
even though they look corny to a lot of
people but it was all modern technology
so when you quickly looked at it looked
like a pee-wee Herman style [ __ ] bike
with the bell and everything on it but
then it was all this state of the at
[ __ ] it's kind of like a restomod but
like a bicycle version and they had this
one it was like an 11 speed bike and all
like the all the gear changing was like
I can't explain where the [ __ ] was it
was like I guess what you would say the
differential would be on a car
but um just the part that it's usually
just part of the wheel all the gears
were in there I'm not enough of a
gearhead to explain this properly they
had the wires going into the bike it was
all like streamlined it had [ __ ] disc
brakes on the front in the back the
things were crazy crazy so um no wait a
minute I got the [ __ ] pamphlet right
here I swear to God if I wasn't trying
to downsize my life and they weren't so
goddamn expensive I would have [ __ ]
bought one
yeah dude these these bikes they're
really [ __ ] neato a lot of you guys
are gonna think these are nerdy-looking
bugs but I think they're [ __ ] six
they got one called the Detroit era
one's the Bixby and one's the run well
and I'll tell you I'll tell you chief
you know but they're [ __ ] sick man
that's why I wish you know I don't know
how it happened part of it was because
there was sweatshop labor and then you
had the unions and then the unions
became what the [ __ ] [ __ ] were and
then everybody just said you know what
[ __ ] you Union and they just left the
country wouldn't be great if we just
made [ __ ] in this country again I'm tell
me we got to start with weed all right
they got to legalize it on a [ __ ]
federal level and we should make the
best [ __ ] weed in the world
we export that [ __ ] you get the whole
world you know [ __ ] buy an are we
they got the best like the like the way
Cubans got the cigar thing locked down
we should do that with weed okay
the government should [ __ ] stay out
of it
just make it legal and walk away and
then tax the [ __ ] out of it okay
and have your eyes wide shut parties and
[ __ ] some other woman while you look at
your wife getting banged by a senator
whatever it is you've upper 1% people
[ __ ] do all right but just walk away
from that [ __ ] let us grow the Balkan
weed in the [ __ ] world we export it
we make all that [ __ ] money you get
your [ __ ] your skin with the tax
right send it to those console birth the
Federal Reserve whatever the [ __ ] it is
they do all right then you know you pay
off the war and then we just leave right
just give in the tents look we just
[ __ ] will drive those [ __ ] cars
have the [ __ ] blue blood [ __ ] that
run the oil industry just sly
over to the electrical [ __ ] they'll
still make the same amount of money then
we don't have to be over in the
middle-east stick enough [ __ ] nose
and all that [ __ ] we all [ __ ] come
home right you put on a game you got
some solar energy you know you got some
[ __ ] weed I know I'm oversimplifying
all of this yeah I'm over simplifying
all of this anyways I know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about here let me let me do
some advertising reads let's do some
advertising reads man I gotta type in my
[ __ ] password it's of course vulgar I
don't know why because of this [ __ ]
anger that you have in you I don't know
what your problem is you're way too old
to be this angry alright see so
everybody see so every here is something
being a barrel of laughs well a barrel
might not be enough laughs in the days
of horses and buglet well a barrel might
have been enough laughs in the days of
horse and buggies but you live now where
you gotta put your laughs on the cloud
by the way you know what technology I
[ __ ] love you those [ __ ]
headphones that guy gave me right from
Bose Wireless I was against that [ __ ]
going I don't need any more radio waves
going into my brain man I [ __ ] love
them I don't give a [ __ ] what it's doing
to me I don't care if I turn into a
[ __ ] zombie that's how convenient
they are
that's why C so C cells library of
stand-up television and original content
provides streaming laughs up to 1.7 mega
barrels and that's proven by science
with C so you get unlimited access to C
so original series next day late night
hilarious stand-up specials binge worthy
classics sign up now to catch brand-new
stand-up specials like the breakout
special from Fahim pronounced Fahim
Anwar like anwar sadat
there's no business like show business
access see so what asses content from
anywhere at any time using iOS no an
upside is that iOS Android
Roku Apple TV Amazon fire TV Windows or
Xbox one Amazon fire that sounds like a
Columba
ready for the punchline see so it's just
399 per month no joke 3.3 99 per month
for all the comedy you want Anytime
Anywhere ad free just go to see so calm
right now to sign up for one month for
free with promo code Burt at checkout
that C SOCOM spelled SE ESO comm promo
coper C SOCOM promo code / I'm gonna
check out some of those you know cuz
everybody's on Netflix you know I want
to be different man I'm over here on C
so I'm on Amazon man alright me on DS
biondi's me on DS checking out new
stream and me on DS biondi's you balls
will be [ __ ] gleaming
watch a bunch of [ __ ] stand-up
specials rub your taint the material
it's twice as soft as [ __ ] cotton
yabba dabba doo buh doo buh doo buh doo
buh telev ate your underwear game to the
next level with me undies you've
perfected your wardrobe but what about
the stuff nobody gets to see what about
the stuff that actually touches your
junk if you've been settling for
store-bought underwear five packs I have
something that will change your life for
the better me undies what's the first
thing you put on the last thing you take
off its your underwear unless you
Matthew McConaughey make your most
important piece of clothing the best
part it can be with me undies you know I
was just like picturing like a cop at
the end of the day you know takes off
everything from the waist down and now
he's completely naked right and then he
takes off his gun detective you've got
the [ __ ] thing right is that to
Village People for you guys the undies
are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro modal Modell a
fabric three times softer than cotton
and guess what you can save time and
money each month with a monthly
subscription
how much do you [ __ ] your pets that you
gotta have a monthly subscription
I am underwear from like two presidents
ago if you're not ready for their
subscription that's okay you can still
say that's because my undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair just use our
special you
our elmia undies dot-com slash bird and
get 20% off your first pair so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer
you deserve it once and you deserve it
get yourself some new underwear you
[ __ ] animal once again that's me
undies dot-com / / me undies dot-com / /
alright how much time we got left up 28
minutes here and I got a phone call in 7
minutes thank you to everybody that
watched the tour of Phoenix from my yet
to be critically acclaimed and
acknowledged tours of cities I did one
in San Jose that one's going to be
coming up soon it's all on my YouTube
page which I of course do not have in
front of me just look up the Bill burr
tour of Phoenix and you'll be able to
find it we'll send another link out to
it like I told you my [ __ ] YouTube
page that's got to be blowing up soon I
already [ __ ] animator I got some
people doing some [ __ ] right I'll be
doing tours of every [ __ ] City excuse
me that I go to got the hiccups and all
of that [ __ ] alright so here we go what
can we talk about here in the final
couple of minutes all the Bruins the
Bruins had their backs up against the
wall we were after having a nice
comfortable [ __ ] lead we were up to
like a fifth seed we tumbled all the way
down to an eighth seed one point ahead
the Tampa Bay Lightning all right and I
wasn't paying attention to tamp I was
just watching the Bruins lose and then I
looked at the [ __ ] standings cuz one
night I was watching the Lightning
playing the Blackhawks and the
Blackhawks dog dog
we're up [ __ ] four to one and you
know the Lightning start coming back and
I'm [ __ ] enjoyed it
oh [ __ ] 42 what a great game I didn't
realize that that was hurting my team
and they ended up winning in overtime
they got two points today with a with
one point behind us so we beat the [ __ ]
in
we beat Long Island alright Long Island
beat the Islanders they're playing
Brookland figure that one out and and
then Tuesday night we beat the [ __ ] and
pray so tonight who do we got the
[ __ ] staff this is such a Boston week
Fred it is Staz that's who a plane
tonight and the Lightning have the
Detroit Red Wings who are not having a
good year but they you know they always
got some [ __ ] Sergei Fedorov next
phenom coming up you know they're kind
of like the Pittsburgh Penguins where
they just they got the [ __ ] they got
that down man somehow they you know I
mean the Penguins are crazy do they had
[ __ ] Mario Lemieux and Jaromir Jagr
then they had like a [ __ ] 10-year
drought fifteen year drought or whatever
and then they come back with [ __ ] Gino
and Syd
you know and you know something the
Bruins could be like that if we didn't
[ __ ] ship them out all the time you
know we had Tyler Seguin a hey what you
have a [ __ ] Coors Light a get out of
town buddy that's so that's not what we
do here in this racist town this is an
upstanding community so we ship him out
and now look what we got we got [ __ ]
posture knocks become you know he's
become a super Brad Marchand you know
it's just like what if Tyler was still
there we could essentially be rolling
three [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] about
hockey but I mean I don't know we're
always doing [ __ ] like that look at you
look at all the goals Joe Joe Thornton
scored in San Jose for what they never
won [ __ ]
we didn't get [ __ ] for them in the
[ __ ] trade we just didn't want to pay
him but anyways anyways that's that port
we have the Stars today okay the stars
at night are big and byte beeping it up
Texas but Dallas is not deep in the
heart of Texas it's right out there in
the open so we're going to win tonight
I hope but you never know they got Jamie
Ben they gotta [ __ ] Patrick's yep
Patrick shap on the Dallas says the next
f1 race by the way is in not this Sunday
it's gonna be next Sunday and that's in
China in don't you and by the way
speaking of China
I got satellite radio now so I finally
get to listen out the Howard Stern Show
again and his wife has some sort of
cause and you know I'm always you know
worried of a cause dude I only listened
to half of it and I had to turn the
[ __ ] channel Howard was describing
they got some day over there oh I don't
what the [ __ ] they're doing with dogs
where they torture them they scare the
[ __ ] out of them they think that they
have like adrenaline you know high
anxiety it makes the meat taste better
they [ __ ] torture them in front of
the other dogs to make them more for the
dogs here the dog it's I don't let me
give you the rest of it it made me sick
to my [ __ ] stomach so there's a
petition that you can sign to try to get
the [ __ ] animals that are doing that
[ __ ] to stop on Howard Stern calm you
just scroll down and you know I had to
sign that [ __ ] because even if it you
got to do something how to [ __ ] you
do that to a dog you know I mean I know
what all you vegetarians you say well
this [ __ ] they do to cows and all that
you know what you're [ __ ] right
isn't that a way to just you know
[ __ ] give a cow to behind the ear
when it's not even like paying attention
the thing is once you kill one the other
sense it and every day it's [ __ ]
brutal buddy you know the end of the day
a [ __ ] hamburgers delicious I don't
know but you know you can just [ __ ] you
have some cows maybe it's because they
have a billion people over there so
there's not enough cows for people I
don't I don't [ __ ] know but I love
dogs so if you love dogs do Howard Stern
comm sign that [ __ ] petition anyways
and then as far as motorcycle racing
goes I'm gonna try to get into this [ __ ]
because these races are nice increase
races got a little Christopher Walken
these rice is there I'm not going to do
it Christopher Walken all right listen
to [ __ ] Craig Gass or [ __ ] jail or
the next I think the first one of that
season if you want to get into racing
now motorcycle racing is [ __ ] insane
because they still bump each other and
[ __ ] in their own motorcycles doing I
don't know
190 miles an hour that one is on April
9th Sunday April 9th and Argentina and 3
p.m. East Coast time I'll actually be in
San Antonio and let's see so that game
will come on for me at 2 o'clock for me
it's gonna come on at 2 o'clock and I
just have to figure out how the [ __ ] I'm
gonna where the hell I'm gonna watch it
I think it's on Fox but I'm totally into
this [ __ ] I'm totally into it
alright alright that's it everybody go
[ __ ] yourselves have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and I'll talk to you on Monday
also listen to this music here a little
bit of music little music bed here and
then we're going to play you some some
classic Monday morning podcasts at
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning as from a Thursday or a
Monday from a year gone by a lady
roommate hey Bill a huge fan of the show
wanted to see if you had any advice for
this situation I found myself in a
little over a month ago I moved to
Phoenix and moved in with the friend of
God you go up Camelback Mountain yet
that's a [ __ ] great hike you got to
go up that one somebody dies up there
every [ __ ] year which always cracks
me up to be like alone in the wilderness
while you can actually see buildings in
the distance it's gotta be so
frustrating
little ugly-ass [ __ ] Road Runners
alright a little over a month ago I
moved to Phoenix and moved in with the
friend from college no real problems
there but he did have a female college
age roommate that he got along with so
we ended up setting settling on a
three-bedroom alright so it's two dudes
and a chick this is already like a
sitcom this is like [ __ ] Reverse
Three's Company
come on you [ __ ] America was just
like that you know nice and simple I
guess it was probably [ __ ] up then I
was just too young to notice they're
eating a popsicle well there cuz all
please go buddy doo-doo-doo boob Larry's
upstairs 50 years old [ __ ] everything
that moves all right I only know a few
people in town and my work schedule is
brewing it makes it really hard to meet
two too many people over the course of
the week all right so you're setting up
your excuse to why you're already
[ __ ] your friend's friend all right
you know I work alone I can't get to
meet people why go out for [ __ ] when
it's right next door
I get it buddy I get it you know it's
Discovery Channel does the lion go after
the toughest zebra the [ __ ] wounded
one oh the little baby one other one
walking around wearing the [ __ ] juicy
shorts I'm sure by now you've
pinpointing the key word in the above
paragraph female yes I am sir yes I have
so you can see where this is going
my second weekend here we all go out get
sloppy jalopy drunk and she informs me
that she broke up with her boyfriend of
five years ah wonderful so of course I
do the genuinely thing and [ __ ] your
brains out
Oh yo so of course yeah I do the
generally thing and [ __ ] her brains up
or flop around like a dead fish on top
of her it's one of those two once I'm
done I leave I go to my room and we
don't mention and we don't mention you
don't mention it in the morning and it's
not awkward at all ah if I had the
Alleluia song oh that's [ __ ] great
would you guys look down at me if I told
you that I was just jealous of this
person right now that's [ __ ] perfect
and the hardest thing is gonna be for
you to not [ __ ] this up for you not to
develop feelings okay you know that's
gonna be a hard one but if you can
somehow do it you can somehow keep
yourself separated you know you could
just it would be like they'd be like
stamps calm having the post office in
your [ __ ] apartment now you got the
post office apartment and now you have
this [ __ ] machine all
so there I mean it's just tremendous you
know and then all you got to do is just
decide what what kind of food you're
always going out for and you really like
and you buy that appliance speed a
panini maker or a [ __ ] cappuccino
maker
you got that stamps calm and the [ __ ]
machine down the hall and I tell you
that's it get the NFL package call it a
life so anyways he goes work we've gone
about doing this for a few weeks now but
since I'm never home during the week and
she works during the day on weekends we
don't exactly see each other and when we
do we we literally never say anything
about it or hint at it at all etc dude
please don't [ __ ] this up please don't
[ __ ] this up okay he says my question
being as this is the first time
something like this has happened is this
a time bomb waiting to happen
where all the crazy is going to come
flying out like the Ark of the Covenant
or she just rebounding and I'm the free
and clear until I settle in and find
something else
keep in mind keep in mind that Jesus
cries sorry I didn't go to church today
as diaper rose and it is risen he did it
all for you there's no way for you to
thank him um unless you give us a bunch
of money um keep in mind I've never been
accused of being good-looking and she's
pretty cute with a grade-a ass on her
any advice is appreciated and I guess go
[ __ ] yourself um okay all right you did
the right thing you know you got a great
situation and you don't want to [ __ ] it
up you know this is like the first time
I went deep-sea fish and I got a bite
and I looked at the dude next to me am i
doing it right what do I do
I let it run a little bit let it run a
little bit hey bring it right you're
doing the same thing alright so what is
your questioning is this a time what
this this is okay
this there's the wild card that she's a
psycho but she she she would have shown
her colors by now I would think if she
was a psycho you know there would have
been some sort of you know God you work
so much I don't get to see you doing
that you know [ __ ] twisting your arm
here or doing something [ __ ] an
annoying some sort of annoying sort of
touching right so she hasn't done that
she's totally putting out the vibe that
she's basically in the mindset it's this
thing seems like it's exactly what it is
you know she was in a relationship for
five years five years man she's got a
decompress from that alright she likes
to go out and get hammered and get
[ __ ] and go to bed and not see you
dumbass for the whole week all right
just keep it at that this is the deal
you don't ever bring it up either
you don't ever bring it up you just keep
it the way it is all right if she's
barely talking to you you barely talked
to her and you just have fun with it and
this is another thing you do alright
have fun with this [ __ ] what are some
things that you always wanted to do with
the woman and you haven't done yet this
is the girl you do it with all right and
she's gonna probably do it with you too
cuz she doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
which is a great thing what you have sir
is a [ __ ] buddy
congratulations this is your first one
this is what men dream of this is what
men really want for this is what we want
for christmas you know if we could just
have a [ __ ] buddy somebody was clean
with no diseases you know and somehow
then had this pill they could give you
that you drank you know you washed it
down and it got rid of any sort of
[ __ ] guilt it would be perfect but
you're single dude so there's no guilt
so my thing is just don't don't open
your mouth and [ __ ] this thing up all
right you got a great thing going okay
just keep doing what you're doing and
the only thing I would correct is this
whole thing where you say you know I'm
not that good-looking a guy you know
work on your self-esteem
she's pretty cute hey you know good for
her she's got a nice ass why don't you
go [ __ ] do something to it but not
during the week no [ __ ] during the
week you focus on your job you have a
great [ __ ] time I know what you know
I guess eventually if you do meet
somebody and you start bringing them
around there's but there is a potential
but you just got to nip that [ __ ] in the
butt I guess if you actually met
somebody that you liked uh Jesus Jesus
yeah I didn't think about that alright
first first things first before we even
get over to her I mean this is okay
whole new can of worms here dude you
have to be cool first and foremost all
right cuz eventually you know if she
meets some other dude you got to make
sure that you're not gonna flip out so
do not develop any feelings for this
girl and the only way you're not gonna
develop any feelings for this girl is if
you see or once a [ __ ] week and your
banger okay you don't want to know how
many brothers and sisters she has right
it's like Reservoir Dogs you guys
shouldn't even know each other's names
so your name [ __ ] yeah you don't know
you don't you want that right all right
you [ __ ] mr. pink or whatever she's
mr. blonde or mrs. blonde sorry that's
the only thing you got to worry about
alright so and I've learned to just be
totally [ __ ] upfront and honest so if
I got some new girlfriend I would just
tell her what's up so what's your deal
yeah I'm single I'm kind of banging my
[ __ ] roommate once a week you know we
don't you know it's just sort of a [ __ ]
buddy thing Oh does that make you
uncomfortable well alright well then
this relationship isn't gonna work
because you're already uncomfortable
with me now if I got feelings for you I
wouldn't keep banging her but you know
I'm not taking it off the table after
one [ __ ] trip to Applebee's Jesus
Christ free [ __ ] that's like free shoes
for you right
you know I don't know that's all I can
tell you dude you can't control her who
gives a [ __ ] dude
someday you're gonna be 50 and you got
to be married and she's gonna be
bitching at you about something even if
you love her at some point you're just
gonna be reminiscing going you know when
my life was the greatest was when I had
little [ __ ] goddamn three-bedroom
apartment all I had to do was make this
amount of money a week and I had some
chick once a week would just [ __ ] my
brains out and not talk to me for the
other six days goddamn dream you got the
dream sir all right and I don't know but
enjoy it while it lasts
okay I hope I answered your question
I really do you're in a hell of a
situation enjoy it all right
kudos to you I am jealous
hey what's going on this is bill burr
and this is uh this is the Monday
morning podcast this is the official one
that other one that I just left was was
unofficial and was not was not
sanctioned by the Board of Directors of
the Monday morning podcast I've had a
crazy day I've been talking all day long
trying to be cute trying to be funny
trying to sell tickets tonight theater
dates this weekend and I am pretty much
all [ __ ] talked out so this is going
to be a straight-ahead no [ __ ] let's
get right to the meat of the [ __ ]
issue podcast because I'm going to the
Ranger game tonight and I'm going to a
bar first which is stupid I'm going to
get sick but I don't know how to say no
you know I don't know saying no the [ __ ]
else am I going to do you know so
disregard the unofficial podcast which
said that I would be doing this podcast
after the hockey game because I'm not I
just decided to [ __ ] it I'll do a quick
20-minute one with a 19-minute intro if
you're new to my podcast I do one of
these every Monday and I do them right
here on bill burr comm and I also do
them on my myspace page no I am not on
Facebook
if you want to know why I'm not on
Facebook revert to the podcast be on
efficient one before this and even
though it's unofficial it is my official
feeling of [ __ ] Facebook you like
this is footnotes with this podcast
alright this is the deal man every week
I do one of these and I answer people's
questions I read [ __ ] that they find
underrated and overrated I give people
advice I read stories revenge and
whatever else this thing spins in to I
also hate my gigs like for example this
weekend I'm going to be on April 3rd I'm
going to be at the lakeshore Theatre in
Chicago Illinois all the information is
on bird calm myspace.com / bill burr
it's all up there and on Saturday I am
going to be at the Trump marina and that
what it is
I can't remember I think that's what it
is yeah be in Atlantic City at the Trump
marina
why doesn't that sound right when it
comes out of my [ __ ] mouth well
whatever that's why I'm assay I'm going
to be a marina we just added a second
show which is why I've been doing all
this media today which is why I'm
[ __ ] half asleep so I'm going to sign
a little bit drunk but I'm not now that
gig is this Saturday April 4th and I
will be working with young Joe DeRosa
one of the new stars of the Opie and
Anthony show and he will also be on the
Opie and Anthony show with as well I
this whole week I'm gonna be on it
on Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday of
this week that would be March 31st April
1st and April 2nd and Joe DeRosa is
coming on on April 2nd so there you go
look at that I got all my high PIGE out
of the way and I said this is going to
be really quick alright and let's talk
about my gig this past weekend I was
working at the house of comedy in st.
Louis and I had a great time
unbelievable crowds all weekend uh my my
eight-person fan club showed up two
members strong and I want to thank them
for showing up that's the group of
people that followed me to Nashville and
you guys remember that story when they
went to Kansas City you want a quick
recap because we've patched things up
between us actually had a blowout with
my fan club there's only I can who the
[ __ ] gets into a fight with their
[ __ ] fan club all right I just like
Santa have a fan club I feel like a teen
idol like I should be singing some song
about teenage teenage angst you know no
bill we don't yeah I did deal with my
[ __ ] hair slicked back if I still had
hair too slicked back you know I'm
looking over my shoulder like a [ __ ]
gay actor trying to be straight and then
I [ __ ] cat crashed my car and
Mulholland Drive is basically half my
fan club last time they saw me they went
to at least be st. Louis chapter
basically they went to Kansas City when
I was working the improv I'll say the
story really quick and they came in and
they were excited never dealt Lee they
were being loud so I'm sitting in the
greenroom and the bouncer comes back and
says hey bill there's a there's a table
people out there that really loud they
seem drunk you want me tell them to you
know sort of chill out a little bit
we go up I go sure that'd be great and
evidently the bouncer goes out there and
he says to the fan club he says hey bill
burr told you guys to shut the [ __ ] up
or something like that
so naturally they were beside themselves
and for some reason decided to continue
to drink so they could have a nice
rational conversation about it after the
[ __ ] show so the show went next thing
you know I get 20 people coming to me
with hey bill written on their shirt and
they're all telling me what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I am and I had nothing to do
with it and I explained myself on a
podcast about it I don't know when the
[ __ ] it was this was years ago
and but anyway since the first time I've
met any of them since then and they were
nice they didn't try to kick the [ __ ]
out of me so evidently everything is all
good so I want to say thanks to them for
coming out and also thanks to that crew
of guys from the University of Kansas
that's right [ __ ] gets it right
now around a laptop high-fiving each
other probably doing drugs legal or not
legal I want to thank all those guys
those [ __ ] on college kid money
you know drove all the way from
basically the other side of Kansas City
to come onto my show which was really
flattering on college kid money unless
they got one rich friend which they
probably do there's always one rich
front and you act like you're friends
with them I want to blow up this spot
right now act like you're [ __ ]
friends with them and you're really not
he just had gas money in the [ __ ] car
you know then all of a sudden you wreck
it and then what do you do you have the
guy you should be in a biker gang but
for some reason he's still in college
welds a new front end to it you turned
it into a float and then you do a bunch
of [ __ ] that would be considered a
terrorist act in the air with the whole
9/11 Patriot Act you'd never get away
with it right sound familiar
all right Animal House reference for all
you youngsters out there all right so
this is the Monday morning podcast this
is going to be a lean mean one in these
lean mean times of a [ __ ] up economy
anybody else who do I did the right
thing with their money and they're sick
of people telling them that they have to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps
it's like no I don't know I don't I have
to [ __ ] I have to what do I have to
do I don't know what I had to pick
myself up off the floor because yet dumb
[ __ ]
ass knocked me down to it I didn't do
anything you know this all the time and
making fun of that MTV Cribs lifestyle I
should have been living it everyone
else's doesn't make a [ __ ] difference
in the end you know I'm trying to figure
a way out man I'm trying to get off the
wheel trying to stop running on the
wheel and I can't
these [ __ ] bankers got the whole
thing sewed up for where I go there's
another dick in my face there's no way
to [ __ ] escape this [ __ ] I'm really
just going to have to work until I'm 106
and then I'm going to die and then
that's going to be the end of it you
know you think I don't have dreams I
don't want to retire open some [ __ ]
stupid-ass bar down on the Florida Keys
sit there in a Hawaiian shirt you know I
mean as I suck in sell drinks to
convicted felons and gay mass murderers
who are on the run because they killed a
[ __ ] sorry I can remember how that
one went runtiwa andrew cunanan
reference there really kill Versace I
saw a really good-looking woman sort of
down you know you know like my girl gets
like so good-looking is so supermodel
looking that they kind of look like an
alien I was actually doing this
interview with this guy's John McCarthy
who has his own [ __ ] website which
escapes me the name of it escapes me
because I'm half asleep and I did ten of
those interviews today but we were
looking at this woman we like she's
beautiful isn't she yeah she's unique
he's like it kind of looks reptilian
there's something about like once you're
taller than 511 as a woman and you still
are somehow under a hundred and twenty
pounds you know your eyes get really big
you just you walk like literally alien
you know what they look like they don't
they look like big praying mantises
praying mantises that you want to [ __ ]
okay
anyways let's get to the podcast
questions like I said this is going to
be a real quick one look at us we're
only ten minutes in and Mario on the
questions all right bill I love this
question by the way because this
question needed to be asked bill what
the [ __ ] is the deal with Edie Hardy
shirts can everybody just relax take a
big inhale and then exhale and just be
happy that somebody questioned those
[ __ ] things I'm gonna read it again
so much I love this question bill what
the [ __ ]
is the deal with Edie hardy shirts seems
like it has become the uniform of the
power tool am i an ass for not realizing
these aren't the cool these are the
coolest things women might ask for not
realizing these are the coolest things
ever or am i accidentally smart for
realizing that I don't need to wear a
dress sure with the drawing of a dragon
[ __ ] Buddha thanks in advance for
help
Todd you couldn't be more right I don't
I don't get those that you know what
those things are going to be you know
every period I'm going to talk about
fashion right now every period has a
moment where somebody wears you know a
style comes out where you know that you
know 10 20 years down the line when they
do the Dazed and Confused movie of that
period that's like you know they'll try
to act like everybody was wearing that
[ __ ] Jesus Christ bill say what you
trying to say put it this way I was
alive during the 70s but I never wore
bell-bottoms you know what I mean I
never had a big pink comb in my back
pocket with feathered back hair Brandon
my hair used to be like a [ __ ] brillo
pad so I couldn't do it but you know I'm
saying well we know whenever they do a
movie about the 70 everybody looks like
that you know what I mean everybody
dresses like that that's what those Ed
Hardy shirts are those are the horrific
fashion mistake of of this time period
they're [ __ ] horrific and not only
that that whole a bunch of drawing on
your shirt I wasn't that in like three
years ago
I mean when I was still trying to be
young three years ago at a a at a very
very tipsy 37 years old I you know I
started wearing shirts like that there
were those shirts were initially for the
people who weren't man enough to get a
tattoo over their entire torso and I
remember like literally like I think
like a year and a half ago I was just
like you know at these least [ __ ]
bedazzled shirts with the Eagles and the
[ __ ] I don't know anteaters on them
whatever the hell they are with all
these like prison tattoo designs this
shit's over and evidently it isn't the
continuing with them and ed hardy
doesn't like these
uh it's like those awful designs and
bright colors you know seems like they
would wear them and the growing up gaudy
sort of kids seems like they would wear
you know big where I mean they'd still
get [ __ ] you know because they got the
because they got the attitude you got
the end there you go red now you get the
attitude that movie Fast Times at
Ridgemont High every movie reference I'm
going to make is going to be [ __ ] 30
years old at this point all right you're
absolutely right I don't know what the
deal with ed hardy shirts are they're
[ __ ] horrific and not even our median
guys wear them they at least as far as I
know they seem to wear those other
bizarre but they're bizarrely designs
and they step out of Maseratis or at
least to Armenian guys did at a car wash
I saw in LA so now that becomes every
Armenian guy in my mindset but that even
[ __ ] makes sense I don't care okay
I'm working on five hours sleep and I've
been running my mouth all [ __ ] day
and yes I will be giving excuses every
five seconds for this podcast all right
question of a - bill I'm recently new to
your podcast but thanks to iTunes of the
participative my podcast question is do
you follow the World Cup soccer in
general if so do you root for any team
specifically and if not you should
consider the Seattle Sounders then come
up to Seattle for a show and a game the
Seattle Sounders alright just when I
thought ed hardy was going to be the
worst thing I could picture in my mind
I'm just picturing the crew of people
who sat around a [ __ ] conference
table and came up and with the name for
your soccer team dude I'm not [ __ ]
on soccer before I trash the name of
your team let's get back to the first
question do I follow World Cup soccer no
I don't I would love to you know I I've
tried to follow that uh what the Premier
League I try to get into because I think
it is cool as hell and I actually I
actually like soccer you know I actually
like it I know a lot of Americans don't
like this [ __ ] but I actually like it
but I don't like American soccer just
because Americans don't seem to be into
it that much so it just kind of seems
like you're watching the WNBA there's no
excitement in the crowd and you know I
can't
excited if no one else is excited
because I'm codependent so uh the only
time I follow the world cup is when they
actually have the world cup and when I
watch it I just root for the countries
that I am you know that my ancestors
were I guess
I'm German Irish with a little bit of
English so I pretty much just I root for
Germany because I think it's funny it's
just funny to root for Germany to be in
a crowd of people rooting for Germany
it's just so [ __ ] cliche like Nazi
esque you know I mean there's no way to
[ __ ] sit there in a crowd full of
people be cheering on Germany and
somehow not feel like you're advocating
me policies of Adolf Hitler that's what
I that's what I like about rooting for
Germany is the you just start laughing
halfway through it like hey wait am I
not the oh intimate no no I'm just
rooting for the soccer team that's right
that's right and I also root for the
teams in South America because evidently
if they miss a penalty shot they go home
and they get executed so but you know
there can only be one winner so getting
back to uh the Seattle Sounders I get it
what because what is what is outside of
the Puget Sound I know there's some sort
of sound I just hate that [ __ ] word I
gotta look it up again what the [ __ ] is
a sound you know something I don't know
that I could define any sort of body of
water other than an ocean I know what an
ocean is right I know what the [ __ ]
ocean is we trying to psych myself up so
I can answer this an ocean is it's a lot
of water in water between continents
what else does it have well it has
sharks it has salt water I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] what does this sound I'm just
going to type sound and let's see what
happens here sound is a vibration
transmitted that's not what I'm talking
about
hang on a second sound let's just write
sound water water sound effects
geography the glacier produces a sound
speed
sound house sound in air differs sound
water productions what the [ __ ] alright
how about this
I mean let me write it you got to be a
[ __ ] it's how you find [ __ ] on the
internet what is a sound enter web
Definition sound sound investments you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
am i spelling it wrong how do you spell
sound from water here it is sound
geography let's go to Wikipedia god
knows they're credible in geography a
sound or a Seaway is a large sea or
ocean Inlet larger than a bay alright
what the [ __ ] is in inlet and inlet is a
narrow battery body of water between
islands or leading inland from a large
urban I'm not going to read the rest of
it because it's just going to get
confusing I like that an inlet is a
narrow body of water between islands
okay so a sound is a big inlet a bay
I don't give a [ __ ] in an alley Jesus
Christ I like you should get a
definition and every other word is
highlighted because I know your [ __ ]
it's stupid
so in geography you sounded or Seaway
the large sea or ocean inlet larger than
a bay so I guess it is saltwater ok I
sort of get what that is so that it's
Sounders alright let's look up Seattle
Sounders let's look this up this is
exciting isn't it Seattle sounder
Jesus Christ you know it's a small club
when there's not even the number one
[ __ ] thing there the third that third
lead on that seattle sounders let's see
do they have history Jesus Christ you
guys are really into that awful green
and blue up there why do you guys always
have this why does everything have to
look like algae when it comes to your
sports teams you know give it an algae
isn't a good team color alright let's
get let's get stop [ __ ] try actually
like soccer and I'm trashing did I
mention the shout-out to the people from
Kansas University let me get back to
[ __ ] anyway what the [ __ ] are we here
alright anyways well here's the kid
hyping up the seattle sounders game
their new MLS expansion team up here and
the atmosphere was electric I suppose
I'm a little biased and miss soccer is
easily the greatest sport in the world
but having been over in Germany for the
2006 World Cup
the Sounders gained felt oddly similar
okay now do you work for the Seattle
Sounders are you really gonna say going
to Germany for the 2006 World Cup
they're going to a home game for the
Seattle Sounders was equivalent to that
evidently he's saying that it's a [ __ ]
and I'm you know go up there and you
have a good time because you'll be
surrounded by AC not a sound not an
inlet of green that was stupid why we
just said that I see not a sound not a
bay that's what I should have said Inlet
that didn't make sense did it because an
inlet it's why she didn't what doesn't
make sense doesn't it what is an inlet I
can't remember see this is why I sucked
in school an inlet in what is a small
straight sort of [ __ ] body of water
between I
you know what if this is sailor listen
to this and once you die hope you're
enjoying this because I know you [ __ ]
laughing but just know that you dress
like you're in the Village People all
right let's get on to the revenge story
shall we uh how do we do over eight
other where because I got it close with
the revenge stories because these things
are so [ __ ] long and not to mention
there's a guy talking a little bit of
[ __ ] about some of your other revenge
stories all right let's get overrated
under raid all I have this week is one
overrated because this is going to be
the stripped-down send me a text message
alright the stripped-down version okay
over I gotta end this thing is five
minutes so I got a hurry here for also
want to miss my drinking time overrated
uh thanks for the a little talk it did I
got an overrated for you [ __ ]
relationships why in the hell can't guys
get out get on the damn boat already the
single guys have it down wine um dynam
[ __ ] and [ __ ] leave I guess it's
like you said I'm sorry to like I can't
I usually suck at reading them just
really even worse fine i'm dinah man you
[ __ ] leave that's other single guys
do it I guess it's like you said I think
it was two podcasts ago or so you feel
the gravitational pull to get married
and have kids I guess us guys had the
same poll about being dumb enough to try
and make a relationship work yeah I
think there's a lot of truth is I think
what you should do is you should just
remain single for your entire 20s you
know and right time right about the time
you're like thirty then you know once
you get all your [ __ ] out of your
system then you can just kind of be like
alright I need to I need to you know
you're gonna want to hang with somebody
at some point you know you don't be the
old guy in the bar like me like I'm
about to be in 45 minutes you know hey
there's sugar you know Colin London by
old old Rat Pack names alright well
let's get on to the UH the revenge story
I'm going to read this guy's first
because he's talking a little bit of
trash and I like this guy scum calm
he's coming out really confident alright
revenge story number one bill it seems
if all the seems like all the revenge
stories that you've been reading on the
podcast lately have been send sent by a
bunch of tansy
that take the [ __ ] passive form of
revenge and [ __ ] with somebody's car
[ __ ] like that is lame and a pathetic
attempt to get back at someone what they
really need to do is take a more
aggressive approach here is my revenge
story and I want you guys to know this I
haven't even revived even read this one
yet alright I just saw that intro I'm
like well with an intro like that this
has to be the best revenge story we've
heard so far so with that let's all
judge this guy's revenge story as I read
it for the first time and I want you to
know the things like [ __ ] nine pages
long goddamn people tell you revenge is
a quick what the [ __ ] did I just do
revenge is not a quick thing here hang
on I just accidentally hit the wrong
button alright I'm back I'm back alright
here we go
the revenge story hi Bill this happened
a few years ago when I was 17 and
working at a fast-food joint one night I
was closing the place and I was rolling
a blunt at one of the tables to smoke
after I got off of work in other words
he was a typical [ __ ] fast-food kid
so anyways a new a new kid that just
started working there a couple weeks
before thinking he was doing the right
thing oh dude you ready red you know
half the [ __ ] isn't my problem you guys
don't write in complete sentences and he
was a new kid it's kind of rolling up
[ __ ] and joined a goddamn table in the
new kid thought he was doing the right
thing and he turned me into the manager
on duty that night
the manager laughed at him because he
couldn't care less about what I was
doing or the fact that his employees
smoked weed that was no nice what a
great manager next day when I go into
work that same manager tells me what
happened the night before I'm not pissed
but I'm more like you know what the [ __ ]
that this guy would run to the manager I
think they some sort of whistleblower I
decide so I decide that the guy needs to
learn his lesson Jesus Christ nice that
up so far enough for you guys I'm
enjoying this so anyways I call up a
friend of mine to get what I need and
when the kid goes on his break and
orders his lunch when he's not looking
I dropped the
hits of acid I brought two with me in
his drink okay when I read that one I
got two hits of acid okay you know you
guys can you proofread these [ __ ]
things so I don't sound like the dumbest
person you know what he did he took two
hits ass and he dropped him in his
[ __ ] fruit punch so anyways he sits
down and he starts eating and I go back
to work and I wait for it to kick in and
the entertainment to start all right I'm
starting to get gets the vibe of this
story evidently when he says you're
keying the car he doesn't mean that
you're a [ __ ] because you can get into
something face to face evidently this
maniac doesn't think you took it far
enough all right back to the story an
hour later when he clocks back in I can
tell it's beginning to kick in hard i
watch us to do good or [ __ ]
starts to trip balls and freaks everyone
out starts a trip balls and freaks
everyone out nobody else knows what what
is going on with the guy so they lock
him in the back manager's office so this
is really dangerous because he didn't
know he was you've probably never done
drugs he probably thought he was going
crazy that's really dangerous and
[ __ ] hilarious all right when he's in
there he really starts to lose his [ __ ]
and tears the place apart
my manager calls the cops and when they
get there they go back and cuff they go
back and cut them and put them in the
back of a squad car there's a lot of
confusion in the place and everyone
tries to figure out what the hell just
happened the cop starts to question
everyone to try and figure out just what
went on but I play it off dumb just like
everyone else saying he just started to
act crazy
- what do you have a life of crime
you're playing that [ __ ] off not worried
are you going to get caught you want to
work release from prison anyways after
taking everyone's statements the cops
leave and caught the guy off he never
did come back to work or even show his
place face in that place again don't
know if it was out of embarrassment
confusion - what happened sang on
confusion - what happened or outright
fear of the place so
I don't know whatever happened to it
still is the best 15 bucks that I ever
spent
Jesus Christ dude that's [ __ ]
hardcore man
I like why you confuses I don't know why
I don't know if he was embarrassed if he
was confused dude you don't think he
figured out what the [ __ ] happened and
he wasn't able to put [ __ ] one and
one together and make two how big that's
what I just say really said rather than
say put two and two together and get
four this is so easy this is one in one
let's see I read it out so I mean people
do you think he read it out for doing
drugs in the last 24 hours
but all of a sudden he starts [ __ ]
tripping wow I'm such a sadistic [ __ ]
there would be a part of me that would
really enjoy that especially if he was
like like always doing the right thing
you know what I mean you know people who
always [ __ ] up in life just really hate
people who are doing the right thing you
know I told them I talked to you about
these people they called [ __ ] and as
much as I hate [ __ ] I really am one
when it comes to certain kinds of people
I have no tolerance for people who are
[ __ ] I don't and it's not because I'm
a tough guy probably reminds me of a
certain part of my personality that I
don't like but in general you know who
goes on and tells somebody you know what
[ __ ] that guy what was he trying to take
you a position at the frialator sit
could be [ __ ] douchebag of the month
wow that really must have
psychologically damaged him and me think
about that you know his whole life that
mama's boy he probably always like you
know Eddie decided sandwich and now we
swim and he didn't wait 15 minutes well
that's very good Mike he always got
rewarded for it any [ __ ] rat you up
hey you know that [ __ ] you know guy
over there smoking weed and then the man
is just so that's like yeah that's what
you do we work in a fast-food joint do
you think this was our dream in life for
the love of God somebody give me a hit
because I can't take the [ __ ] pain a
reality anymore don't you go mop
something up your little [ __ ]
that's probably what happened the next
day say jeez if I went home talk to his
mom I couldn't believe it golly Jimmy
I mean he was doing he had a marijuana
cigarette well don't you worry you did
the right thing
okay and you just stay away from him and
you go to work tomorrow and you make
sure you do a good job and he goes to
work and he [ __ ] [ __ ] puts the
date rape drug in there
that's a date rape drug you know I'm
saying puts acid in there Jesus Christ
imagine you never even imagine you've
never even had a sip of beer and the
first thing happens you used to hit the
acid I never took acid thank God thank
God thank God I never ratted out
somebody doing drugs um anyways alright
here's here's another revenge story I'm
gonna read this one then I got to wrap
it up hey Bill uh I'm with you on the no
revenge rule people suffer
oh this isn't even a revenge thing this
is just a question this guy needs some
advice this this falls into the ass bill
portion of the podcast the advice people
like to ask me for advice even though
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] we could read this
whole thing because uh anyways I was
running to you to talk about okay here's
the probably s/he needs some advice
anyways bill I was running to you talk
about my [ __ ] of a girlfriend and
hopefully to get some advice I love how
[ __ ] has just become the catchphrase of
the podcast here anyways me and my
girlfriend have been together for about
two and a half years we knew each other
as teenagers along with some other
people she dated she dated one of our
friends and he eventually moved on and
got married me and her remained friends
and eventually we became close we
started dating she isn't the best
girlfriend well yeah I figured that
considered you're calling her a [ __ ]
yeah because she had a couple of things
that annoyed you she is the best
girlfriend but I have become pretty
pretty comfortable having her around and
were two kids not for me yeast love or
two kids not for me they love me and we
have become quite the family here is
where [ __ ] went wrong recently we
visited our friends in New York and we
are all partying and [ __ ] and I get a
horrible headache and sit down on the
couch to rest it up I was out of it for
like 30 minutes and I wake up to a
nightmare
I hear my friend in the kitchen hitting
on my girlfriend Wow if it's a if that's
not bad enough she's into the [ __ ] and
encourage him encouraging him and
flirting back after I had all I could
take
I watch into the kitchen and they made
the oh [ __ ] face when they looked at me
but I didn't say anything then I didn't
say anything then in there
the next night for possibly the same or
possibly the same night since I was
hammered every day I was with hair me
and my girlfriend go to bed in the guest
room while we are laying there she gets
up to go to the bathroom and after she
didn't return after about 15 minutes I
opened the door and what do I see him
and her standing here alone in the
hallway having a quiet conversation
Jesus Christ dude this is getting creepy
here's her story she was just
entertaining herself and it wasn't going
to go anywhere she feels she didn't
sleep with him or anyone else so I'm
overreacting I'm overreacting by
considering breaking up considering all
we really she have to lose all
considering all that you guys have to
lose yeah it's really her with the two
[ __ ] kids all right so anyway she's
been walking around crying on the set
about the [ __ ] she has told me she is
sorry and it will never happen again
she has been pretty much worshipping me
the last few days and the [ __ ] is
starting to eat away at me I also know
that I purchased most of the [ __ ] in
this house and if / when we separate I
will be taking most of it with me and
that is going to make it a lot more
difficult and painful for her and her
kids at this point I might [ __ ] all of
this and I am ready to leave I'm ready
to leave and [ __ ] but honestly I'm
starting to feel like a real douche for
not being able to get past this [ __ ] the
kids will be devastated and they're
pretty much doomed once I leave because
I'm pretty much the glue that holds this
family together at the same time I feel
like if she would do this [ __ ] after
years what kind of Hope does that give
us for the future what kind of
relationship can we have after some [ __ ]
like this I would love some feedback on
this bill even though you never read my
letters during the podcast insert guilt
here just tell me what you think I
should do in this situation all right
dude
you're in that classic halfway point
between emotion you know for your
feelings for the kids you're in the
halfway point between that and knowing
exactly what the [ __ ] you need to do and
you're doing what you need to do you
need to reach out to people who are
going to read affirm what you know in
your heart of hearts what you have to do
is you have to get the [ __ ] out of there
you got to get out of there all right do
you think that's the first guy she hit
on you know and if she's hitting on guys
that means she's probably [ __ ] other
guys and if she's not she's going to and
right now she's just in a panic mode and
she's in a panic mode not because she's
worried about losing you because of all
that other [ __ ] that you mentioned
because you sound like you're the most
responsible of the people there and the
only [ __ ] hope her kids have is that
you'll stick around because she is I
don't know she doesn't ever shift
together um
you got to get out dude you got to get
out and you know you you might be good
for the kids right now but eventually
you're not going to be because the
misery that you're going to have being
in a relationship with somebody that you
can't trust as far as you can [ __ ]
throw them it's eventually going to rub
off on how you feel about the whole
situation and it's going to be really
hard to be not to be a [ __ ] douche
around because kids you're probably
going to start drinking and eventually
you're going to start a [ __ ]
relationship and the longer you're there
the more [ __ ] you're going to buy so
this is what you got to do you got to
give yourself [ __ ] six weeks all
right just break it up in two week
increments the first two weeks is going
to be brutal just cry on the floor with
a pint of [ __ ] POG and dust like a
little [ __ ] and get through it and
every time you want to call that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that you can't trust anymore you call a
friend of yours instead you call a buddy
of yours the kind of buddy who's going
to [ __ ] and take you out drinking and
get you back in the [ __ ] game that's
what you do all right and you do that
and turn that time the last [ __ ]
thing you do is get into another
relationship
all right don't [ __ ] do that don't do
the JLo will you get out of that you
jump into something else
[ __ ] that all right you stay [ __ ]
single you know and just just get
through six [ __ ] weeks and gradually
and it did after two weeks goes by you
know to me you start having a life you
start going down the park playing
frisbee with your next-door neighbor I
know what the [ __ ] you'll start filling
up the time that's all it is in the
break-up have a mitt you know after like
a few days unless you really love
somebody you're already getting past
them what you're really trying to do is
wondering well what the [ __ ] that I do
during all this time how did I use to
fill up my free time and that's what you
got your boys for they'll take you out
go drinking go to games you know buy the
big [ __ ] industrial-sized box of
condoms just [ __ ] you know bang away
do all the [ __ ] you got to do it but
dude you got to get out of that
relationship you know you got to get our
relationship and it sucks but you know
what dude it's a [ __ ] it's a
20-minute conversation 20 minutes what
what you have to say takes [ __ ] 30
seconds but you got to deal with [ __ ]
the next 20 minutes all her [ __ ]
trying to use all these different
techniques to try and get you to stay
she's going to go with the guilt she's
going to go to the stereo she's gonna go
with anger she's going to [ __ ] unload
her female [ __ ] gun of emotion at you
and you just have to stick to your
[ __ ] you got to stick to your guns
I'm out I'm out because you [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up I can't trust you I can't
trust you the relationship is over
relationship is over
it's over not only were you hitting on
another guy hitting on my best friend
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you untrustworthy
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you get the balls to
sit here and act like I'm going to
[ __ ] stay with you are you out of
your [ __ ] mind
wait a minute strike that don't say that
mean [ __ ] don't say that mean [ __ ] cuz
then then you don't do don't do like
that just say look I can't trust you you
know what yeah [ __ ] that I don't what
the [ __ ] up spin you know what you got
to do alright but don't don't don't
don't get sucked into a you know [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you fight with her alright and
she's going to do the usual [ __ ] that
women always do when she gets to the
anger thing
she'll go with she'll go with the usual
chill somehow she'll question your
sexuality if your your ability in bed
should probably do that well maybe if
you [ __ ] blah blah blah I wouldn't be
hitting on your friend she's just gonna
do that in a last-ditch hope that you're
gonna turn around blast her in the
[ __ ] face so she can get a little
more money out of you and you can go to
jail and she can keep your [ __ ]
PlayStation so don't get sucked into
that when she says that remark just be
like yeah you know what
yeah I guess I guess I do suck in bed so
you know have fun [ __ ] my friend you
know you seem like you really want to
you know or whatever now that was lame
you know most of that was good
okay don't get sucked into that don't
get sucked into any sort of domestic
violence thing all right I'm not trying
to judge you but that's a really
white-trash
sort of situation you're involved in
there well you got this you know me dude
you said in the beginning that you
[ __ ] thing yeah I'm kind I'm only
kinda into this girl and she's got two
[ __ ] kids you don't to me this is why
you got to stay single dude you got to
figure out what the [ __ ] is with you
that you got yourself into this mess to
begin with
alright but dude it could have been
worse you could have [ __ ] it you could
add up its what there he could've been
married
hey yeah they could have been she could
have been [ __ ] poisoning you every
morning you know those girls they don't
have to break up with you so they start
putting [ __ ] that's cyanide in you
and you goddamn Rice Krispies all right
dude I'm telling you I'm telling you get
the [ __ ] out you know what to do alright
get the [ __ ] out call one of your
friends be listen to it I got to get out
of this situation it sucks so I'm gonna
need you over the next six weeks
anytime I call you and I'm like I need
to go out booze and you gotta be there
you and your [ __ ] liver have got to
be there for me you know that's what you
got to do
alright there you go I know I just said
the same thing for [ __ ] 20 minutes
but you know I've been in that situation
never with the two kids but you got you
got you got to go dude you got to go
alright
all right there grasshopper that make me
proud and send me an email in the week
and tell me that you got the [ __ ] out of
there alright alright that's it that's
the Monday morning podcast god bless all
you I hope to see you out of one of my
shows